the california recall effort was a
complete and total dud newsome won with
an extraordinary percentage of the vote
he he survived the recall effort by a
margin of 64 to 36
that's with 70 of the vote in
and um
in the question of who was going to
replace him larry elder was leading with
of the vote the california governor
recall exit polls via nbc news show that
the the desire to recall
newsome was not
was not held by a majority of
californians anywhere in the poll right
only 47 percent of of males only 46
percent of males wanted to recall them
only 38 of women wanted to recall them
only 44 of white voters wanted to recall
them only 19 of black voters wanted to
recall them so this is just a textbook
blowout and that is because california
is a completely blue state so the the
bad news for california is that
california is uh apparently irredeemable
and now in an inevitable state of
complete collapse and decline because
there is no desire to actually reverse
any of that that's been true for a while
the good news is i don't have to think
about moving back so i guess that's good
news uh that is that is pretty much what
the the recall effort shows
they did ask folks
about some of the issues that had come
up
on these uh uh in the recall effort
particularly covid policy
and what they found is that
a
large percentage of californians are
very comfortable with coveted policies
that were put forward by by gavin newsom
uh something like 46 percent of
californians said that they thought that
they were about right that this is all
pretty good
it all worked just fine
in fact a significant percentage of
californians thought that the coveted
policies were actually not strict enough
they should have been stricter
apparently only 32 percent of
californians thought that the policies
were too strict
so they're getting what they deserve
right good and hard this is the l
mankind line about democracy being the
theory that the voters ought to get what
they want good and hard this is what
they are getting good and hard
26 of the people who voted in the recall
strongly approved of gavin newsom's
performance as governor another 28
somewhat approved so about 54
and uh you know not not a huge
percentage of people
actually
disapproved of them it's like 43
disapproved so it's a pretty heavy win
for gavin newsom for his part gavin
newsom said that this was a referendum
on trumpism which is kind of wild
donald trump number one was not on the
ballot but number two
you shouldn't be this triumphal about
surviving a recall effort in california
which is a heavily democratic state
this is like saying that ben shapiro
survived a recall effort at the daily
wire right like i
own the place the democrats own the
place so for gavin the shock would have
been if gavin newsom had actually been
recalled and let's not be
ridiculous about this the recall effort
here was significantly less likely to
succeed than the recall effort of gray
davis back in 2001 2002
back when gray davis was recalled during
that period we were like four years
removed from a republican governor the
last time california had a truly
republican governor was pete wilson in
the late 1990s
so a full generation
anyway here was gavin newsom trying to
suggest that this was his triumphant
return he had triumphed over trumpism
this is what democrats are going to try
and do by the way it's a good
reminder this is the democratic plan for
2022 and 2024 they want to run against
trump they want trump on the ballot they
want to make it all about trump
which is why if you're a republican even
if you like trump a lot you might want
to think a little bit seriously about
whether you want trump back on the
ballot because it does get democrats out
to the ballot box for sure trump is good
at republican turnout and he's even
better at democratic turnout in any case
there's gavin newsom trying to push that
point i i said this many many times on
the campaign trail
you know
we may have defeated trump but trumpism
is not dead in this country
the big lie
january 6 insurrection all the voting
suppression efforts that are happening
all across this country
what's happening the assault on
fundamental rights constitutionally
protected rights of women and girls
it's a remarkable moment
in our nation's history
uh it's not a remarkable moment in our
nation's history it would have been
remarkable as if you'd been dumped
again this would be the equivalent of
the governor of alabama surviving a
recall election against a democrat like
that's that is not a particular shock
and the media portraying it as a shock
is kind of shocking in and of itself the
real shock is that it went this far
nonetheless according to
dny news
they say california basks in its
clairvoyance the future happens here
first says governor gavin newsom calling
his state america's coming attraction uh
well that's why i left by emphatically
turning back the effort to recall him
from office however mr newsom made clear
california's cherished role presaging
the politics of tomorrow was not as
significant as another larger factor in
tuesday's results the tribal politics of
today the first term democratic governor
will remain in office because in a
deeply liberal state he effectively
nationalized the recall effort as a
republican plot making a flame-throwing
radio host the trump-like face of the
opposition to polarize the electorate
along red and blue line so the
suggestion here and this has been the
suggestion of the media is that if larry
elder had not been the candidate for the
republican party most likely to replace
gavin newsom then newsom would have done
worse in the recall effort now that may
be true in the sense that larry is a
very strong political personality with
very strong views
but again this is a heavily democrat
state the notion that he was going to
get recalled at all was probably
a bit of a pipe dream
and even when the polls narrowed
significantly and got to the point where
it was really really narrow that was
when they were not talking about any of
the people running against him if it had
not been larry they probably would have
done this to kevin cal falconer for
example
so
again the media are treating this as as
a referendum on sort of conservatism
more generally
and they're attempting to make it a
referendum on trumpism and it really had
nothing to do with either it had to do
with the fact that the z heavy i can't
say it enough it's a heavy blue state
they have a super majority in the
legislature the democrats do
so if they'd replaced
newsome with any republican that would
have been a grave shock
mr newsome found success not because
what makes california different but
because of how it's like everywhere else
he dominated in california's heavily
populated democratic cities the key to
victory in a state where his party
outnumbers republicans by five million
voters by the way this should be a
reminder if you're a republican in
california things are going to get worse
not better i've been saying this since i
left
right follow me get out while the
getting is good move to a purple state
turn that state red california is a lost
cause i know there are a bunch of people
who are hanging on over there i was one
of them until a year ago
i i'm much happier now that i have left
the state the state is again in an
inexorable state of decline the voters
there are not interested in turning away
from the path that they are now trotting
they're not turning away from higher
taxes they're not turning away from more
regulation they're not turning away from
from terrible records on on crime and
horrible records on education they're
not turning away from any of that stuff
they're embracing it
they're embracing the suck so get out
while the getting is good
there's plenty of opportunity in other
states
so that is the takeaway from the
california election is that the
continued sorting effect is going to
continue
and that we are going to be a country
where the red states become redder and
the blue states become bluer and the
purple states will either shift over
into red or blue and then follow that
path inevitably
as virginia has right virginia went from
purple to blue and now it seems like
it's going to continue moving blue seems
to be the trend over in virginia
on the other hand ohio went from purple
to red and seems like it is going to get
more red over time florida moved from
purple to red and seems like it's
getting more red over time california is
going to move from blue to deep blue to
like dark night blue
that's what's going to happen in the
country and the predictable result of
that is going to be further polarization
at the federal level
so on a national level why should we
care about california because what it
actually presages is not just politics
in california what it presages is a
question whether we actually do want to
remain part of the same body politic if
we do want to remain part of the same
body politic we're going to have to
construct a system of a federal
governance in which texas can be texas
and california can be california
however california has to let texas be
texas
and herein lies the rub because the
federal government has no interest when
run by democrats in allowing texas to be
texas they would like texas to be
california
and if that's the case what you're going
to end up with is a fairly ugly split
between states that wish to be left
alone and states that wish to run their
business from the top level of the
federal government
i think this is why you're hearing so
much talk these days about a quote
unquote civil war or talk about
secession or talk about the country
breaking apart
it's a serious question whenever you
form a body politic which is what
happened at the founding and what
happened again in the aftermath of the
civil war if you form a body politic
you have to decide whether you wish to
remain part of the same country and if
so what common rules can you hold at the
top level that everybody can agree to
well if the basic notion of american
government is that the federal
government's going to make all the rules
and it's just going to be a struggle for
the power of the one ring
then this country is not going to last
this way it is just not and maybe then
the best hope for a lot of conservatives
and maybe for a lot of liberals
depending on who's in control of that
federal government is uh a friendly
separation
that is what that force ages
okay not that california is the wave of
the future but the california
and its polarization is the wave of the
future and that we're going to get i
promise you in the aftermath of this
real estate values in florida are going
to go up real estate values in arizona
in texas and nevada they're going to go
up because republicans are going to
continue leaving
and maybe that's what the california
politicians want
so be it
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment